the number of people hospitalized with
cova 19 has been a key statistic in
forming policy throughout the pandemic
but not all covet hospitalizations are
created equal as the omicron wave puts a
strain on healthcare systems across
canada some jurisdictions have started
separating hospitalization numbers based
on whether a patient was admitted for
cover 19 or for other reasons but tested
positive during screening the latter are
often known as incidental covet
hospitalizations that means not everyone
who is in hospital with covid was
admitted because of covid however the
country's top doctor says the key thing
to remember when setting public health
policy is that hospitals are still
stretched thin whether a patient has
incidental covid or not
i guess the bottom line is this variant
is having a very significant impact on
the hospitalizations but the other thing
that's very different is that of course
staff are getting sick at the same time
so that is putting a lot of pressure on
the hospital systems
the numbers vary from province to
province with about one-third of coveted
hospital admissions in saskatchewan
being considered incidental while in
ontario that number is closer to half
icu numbers also differ from province to
province for example ontario has 82
percent of cova 19 patients in the icu
admitted for covid as of january 18th
compared to 18 percent who are
considered incidental infectious
diseases specialist dr isaac bogash says
determining which cases are incidental
can be difficult
you have people who have a copin 19
infection who have overt signs and
symptoms of copa 19 that bring them into
hospital sometimes you have people who
have a cova 19 infection but it
exacerbates an underlying medical
condition so someone has an exacerbation
of their emphysema someone has an
abnormal heart rhythm someone has a fall
and a lot a lot of this was driven by a
copa 19 infection it's very
i'd be very curious to see how those
individuals are categorized some people
of course have something completely
unrelated to coven 19. totally unrelated
they come into hospital and have an
incidental finding of cope at 19. it's
important to know some people acquire
copa 19 in hospital as well it's also
important to know dr nathan stahl at
mount sinai hospital in toronto says the
number of incidental cova 19 patients
should be interpreted with care when i
look at it it is one piece of data that
i you know question you know the the
proportions and numbers that i'm seeing
based on the challenges with definitions
i
i do not consider it nearly as as
importantly as things like number of
hospitalizations and ic admissions and
staffing shortages and and the
downstream consequences to care also at
issue is the impact a covert positive
patient can have on the health care
system when a person tests positive
whether they were admitted for covid or
with an incidental case it can trigger
the need for more stringent health care
protocols to protect both staff and
other patients dr jesse pappenberg of
montreal children's hospital says that
in turn creates further strain
any person with a saris kobe 2 infection
depending on what type of procedures
done what what what clinical condition
the patient is in may require additional
infection control measures to be put
into place which are burdensome
and costly for the healthcare system
there's also been concern among some
health professionals about whether
releasing incidental data is helpful
stahl is concerned releasing these covet
hospitalization numbers may result in
the downplaying of the severity of the
virus
so if it helps health systems plan for
therapeutics and for anticipated
critical care use and and and that sort
of thing i think it could be helpful it
can be weaponized the data can be
weaponized in so many ways that
downplays a real
difficulty in human tragedy for so many
people across this country provincial
health officials have defended the
decision
it does have an impact on things like
infection control practices in the
hospital
but it does also give us a measure of
where we are in terms of of impact we're
providing this data to inform planning
and in alignment with other provinces
reporting
however it is important to recognize
that any covet covered positive
admission has an impact on our acute
care capacity
opinions are divided on how to interpret
these hospitalization numbers but
canada's deputy chief public health
officer dr howard news says regardless
of why they were admitted the focus
should still be on reducing the overall
burden on the health care system sean
previl global news
thanks for watching global news if
you're interested in more national and
international news be sure to subscribe
to our channel